habla de éxitos en el campo de batalla
en su discurso nocturno el presidente
dijo que las fuerzas ucranianas estaban
progresando en su contraofensiva contra
el ejército ruso
quiero dar las gracias a los Soldados
del Batallón 63 de la brigada 103 de las
fuerzas de defensa territorial que
aseguraron el resultado en la región de
Daniel también quiero mencionar al
Batallón 42 de Infantería motorizada
independiente gracias a sus heroicas
acciones se liberaron dos asentamientos
en el sur de nuestro estado aunque
selenski no ha dado detalles precisos el
ejército ucraniano Está tratando de
recuperar la región de gersón está en
manos rusas desde marzo cuando los
soldados también capturaron la ciudad de
gerson la única capital regional
ucraniana que ha caído desde el comienzo
de la guerra en las redes sociales el
gif post compartió una imagen de tres
soldados izando la bandera ucraniana
sobre una ciudad de la provincia del sur
El comando del sur de Ucrania trabajo
que sus fuerzas estaban atacando las
líneas de suministro rusas y mediante
ataques aéreos y fuego de artillería
Moscú ha declarado públicamente que los
asaltos ucranianos a gerson han sido
repelidos Mientras que el jefe adjunto
de la ciudad respaldado por el kremlin
lanzó una advertencia desafiante
jerson es y seguirá siendo una ciudad
rusa
versión aguanta estamos en primera línea
con los que aguantan
sin embargo el mismo funcionario
reconoció que los planes de celebrar un
referéndum para que la región de gerson
se une a Rusia han quedado en suspenso
debido a la situación de seguridad